[Musica]
sono una biologa molecolare
mi occupavo di estrazione di dna e
pensavo che fosse quello che volevo fare
in realtà a volte i nostri percorsi ci
portano su altre strade ma la vita ci
guida sempre oggi sono un'imprenditrice
o un'azienda di produzione di cosmetici
contempo li
produciamo cosmetici conto terzi la cosa
più bella di tutto questo percorso da
quando è iniziato sono state le persone
che ho incontrato nel mio cammino che mi
hanno aiutato a diventare quello che
sono oggi
perché anche se è vero che
l'imprenditore ha sempre la
responsabilità delle scelte e la
responsabilità dell'azienda
nessun traguardo può essere mai
raggiunto se non insieme
abbiamo tutti bisogno di qualcuno che
creda in noi stessi perché l'essere
umano è molto fragile e spesso anche il
più forte può vacillare
ma ecco che arriva poi il tocco quel
gesto quella parola
tutto questo ci permette di ritrovare il
coraggio e la forza di diventare quello
che eravamo destinati ad essere
io stesso sono frutta di persone che
hanno creduto in me di persone che mi
hanno presentato e introdotto nel mondo
della cosmetica che oggi è diventato non
soltanto il mio lavoro ma anche parte
integrante
della mia vita
quindi io di riflesso scelgo di credere
credo nei miei collaboratori
credo nei miei progetti
credo negli altri con la voglia di
sovvertire gli schemi tradizionali del
fare impresa perché a volte
modificare le regole del gioco del gioco
è qualcosa di positivo
non è stato semplice costruire
un'azienda dal niente un azienda che
nasce e cresce è un sistema dinamico è
un sistema in continuo movimento che in
qualche maniera necessita di tanti
cambiamenti nuovi macchinari nuovi
collaboratori da formare nuovi spazi da
gestire ma quello che ho imparato in
tutto questo tempo è che ciò che dai
torna sempre indietro per questo nella
mia azienda ho cercato di costruire
qualcosa di diverso
cerco al massimo di valorizzare i miei
collaboratori di
andare a carpire quel talento che ognuno
di loro sa di trovare quella luce che
può essere pronta a far brillare ma
spesso non sanno neanche di avere dentro
di loro questo mi ha permesso di
costruire un microcosmo un ambiente in
cui l'essere umano al centro perché
penso che la vita sia un soffio e non ci
possiamo permettere di stare in un
ambiente in cui non si sta bene dare
fiducia e credere di questo abbiamo
bisogno
semplici regole che portano sempre a
grandi risultati
la prima ispezione che abbiamo avuto da
un ente molto importante è andata
veramente molto bene sopra ogni
aspettativa
una cosa molto particolare che accaduta
mentre firmava il verbale era il campo
note nel campo note c'era scritto
azienda che valorizza le competenze
clima aziendale molto favorevole e
spiccato spirito di gruppo la direzione
favorisce attività con benefiche
ricadute sul tessuto sociale
per me è stato emozionante vedere che
qualcuno dall'altra parte metteva nero
su bianco
quello che era il mio desiderio quello
che avrei voluto fare
abbiamo capito che attraverso il nostro
lavoro potevamo fare altro abbiamo
capito che le nostre competenze potevano
essere messe a disposizione della
comunità per questo motivo è nato una
linea di cosmetica oncologica
adesso stiamo studiando una linea per
bambini e affetti da chiusi nel momento
della pandemia abbiamo interrotto le
nostre elaborazioni per produrre solo
gel igienizzante perché vi sto dicendo
questo
perché ci viene sempre data
l'opportunità di scegliere la propria
parte noi tutti possiamo scegliere di
contribuire a quello che è il benessere
di tutti
solo se capiamo che siamo una rete in
cui le maglie che si collegano che si
uniscono sono le nostre vite allora
possiamo davvero fare la differenza
allora possiamo davvero essere la
differenza
uno dei primi giorni di lavoro di una
tirocinante
mi fermai a parlare con lei per chiedere
come come stava andando e dopo avermi
risposto lei mi chiese sai stefania che
cosa vorrei tanto
una bicicletta
io rimasi molto colpita da questa
richiesta molto molto colpita e quindi
molto velocemente trovammo questa
bicicletta
i ragazzi dell'azienda la ripararono e
le ragazze dell'azienda nella loro pausa
pranzo le insegnarono andare in
bicicletta
questa bicicletta per lei ha significato
tantissimo ha significato la capacità di
muoversi ha significato l'indipendenza e
quindi adesso ne ha una nuova a una
bellissima e semplice bicicletta rossa
che le ha regalato semplicemente
qualcosa a cui noi non pensiamo spesso
la libertà di muoversi
per progredire dobbiamo costruire e per
costruire abbiamo bisogno di tante
persone che condividano con noi non solo
le loro menti ma anche i loro cuori sono
le scelte che ognuno di noi compie ogni
giorno che cambiano il corso degli
eventi
tutti noi siamo abituati a combattere ma
non tutti siamo
abituati a
sostenere il senso di solitudine di
solitudine che a volte deriva proprio
per questo allora abbiamo bisogno di
quel qualcuno che ci stia vicino e che
cammina insieme a noi
ogni mattina quando arrivò al lavoro
trovo una sorpresa meravigliosa un
piccolo vaso con dei fiorellini azzurri
all'interno non smetterò mai di
commuovermi perché è un grandissimo
gesto d'amore io penso che è questo di
cui tutti noi abbiamo bisogno gentilezza
comprensione cura
penso che se queste attitudini vengono
messe in pratica nel quotidiano
sicuramente il mondo non lo possiamo
cambiare ma lo possiamo rendere
sicuramente migliore
penso anche che niente accada per caso
young le chiamava le sincronicità lei le
chiama lady o incidenze e forse c'è un
perché se dopo 20 anni le nostre strade
si sono riunite si chiama zia caterina è
una persona molto speciale
tali prima che questo e peso
ma eccoci
siamo proprio pronti caparrini è
cambiata tutta tutta perfetta e
importante vedete cosa succede quando si
sale su un taxi
può succedere tutto è vero tutto ti sei
cambiata se aiuta seria emozionata e ora
che venuto anche tutto il frizzi e non
mi danno più i capelli è perché perché
perché l'emozione aprile
l'emozione abbiamo assistito una serie
di emozioni tutto il giorno dalla falla
a tutta la serie io oblata benedettina
fatto voto di castità proprio dopo tutta
quella cosa sulla sessualità dovevo
venire perché così libriccino e mi
riprendeva
è sì sì sì che cos'è quindi la cavallini
e laterina
che cosa sono come mai si sliding door
slicing la presunta xvi 20 anni fa ma se
noi ricordata dopo vent'anni aveva preso
però né sui tempi insomma però l'ha
preso quando poi era maturato il tempo
bisogno la necessità il momento giusto
lei ha voluto restituire appunto perché
la sua azienda in questo momento da
imprenditore illuminato ha bisogno anche
di illuminare chi illumina illumina
quelle zone buio è evidente cioè insomma
mi sembra abbastanza chiaro no
la situazione è grave anche se adesso
sono un grosso in qualcosa però sempre
racing rossi non lo sapevo però lo sono
da vetta tanti anni perché mi sono
acconciata così da tanti anni della
gamma la mediceo quanto tu ci metti a
vestirti ancora non l'ha capito abbiamo
scritto anche un libro un capitolo
intero sulla vestizione come caspita fai
a uscire di casa con tutte le tue paure
tutti trema la voce 6 insicuro 6 fragile
non sai esattamente
perché sei diverso dagli altri ma lo sei
evidente le si sono sposate tutte anche
dopo il lutto stefano morì 20 anni fa
morì di cancro
io ho vissuto la sua suo calvario e non
potevo rimanere esattamente la stessa
non potevo perché nessuno rimane lo
stesso dopo mi ha scoperto la
straordinarietà di essere vivo io ero
viva e in più lui mi lasciava la sua
vita questo è successo subito come lui
stava morendo e felice di lustig felice
perché era innamorato lascia a caterina
la sua esistenza e poi un taxi un taxi e
dice vabbè ora invece tutti i manager
mero ne vedo un monte di manager
scusate cosa ca scart ska causa sarà mai
lasciare un taxi per lui era il più bel
lavoro del mondo quindi cosa ha lasciato
stefano a caterina stefano a caterina ha
lasciato la motivazione quello stefano
la mi piace parecchio velo vestito tutto
un po chic circa perché mi sei piaciuto
da lontano il ricordo che primo problemi
a me stefano migliaia ovvero mi piace mi
piace perché la sua ecco il coraggio di
stare dentro quello che sentiva io
dovevo solo rimanere dentro quello che
stefano aveva sentito cioè che potevo a
mare attraverso la sua vita quello che
mi aveva lasciato e insegnato
respiro perché non è una nostra semplice
marini a mare oggi di tutto abbiamo
parlato anche di questo ha necessità di
essere innamorati la motivazione
fondamentale che spinge le persone alla
creatività al cambiamento e
l'innamoramento essere innamorati quindi
principalmente cosa cos'è cos'è che ci
rende speciali io e lavori di che io
capisco nulla di quello che è fare
azienda e avevo bisogno di un
imprenditore illuminato che mi dicesse
territorio profumini in viene andare a
trovare una persona ammalata o che mi
faccio io dei profumini
che te ne fai te ne fai quando non c'è
non sai cosa dire perché non è guarita
dalla volta precedente quando le cose
vanno in un determinato senso quando per
uscire non si può andare a fare un giro
in taxi quando i dottori non vengono più
a casa perché è inutile dirti cosa sta
succedendo lo stai capendo da te
eccoli che arriva l'afa farini a parrini
alle alle piane con un profumino che
dice vi faccio un massaggio vengo io e
ti accompagno io sarò per sempre grata
la cavallina infatti mi sono fatta anche
tutto il tedesco e tutte e tutti lo
faccio tutte fin dall'inizio
sono venuta ascolta tutti perché io sono
innamorata di te e di come tu ti sei
posta verso i miei
ragazzi bisognosi in questo caso era
viola viola come tu hai capelli questa
ragazzina straordinaria alla quale io
desideravo dire tante cose ma non potevo
usare la parola classica e quindi in
questo caso il nostro
insieme essere insieme essere creatività
insieme se l'è risposta a un bisogno era
esattamente il fatto che fossimo
innamorate del dolore dell'altro della
difficoltà dell'altra perché da tutto
ciò che crea veramente la necessità
viene è la risposta la risposta e non
c'era la risposta che non che non ti
saresti mai aspettato perché non è testa
e cuore io non avrei mai lasciato viola
lei non mi avrebbe mai lasciato solo
perché un'imprenditrice che voleva dare
una mano a una persona e non aveva
chiaramente tutti gli strumenti perché
quando attivi ti rapporti a ragazzi e
noi raccontiamo attraverso disegni
perché è più facile disegnarli che farvi
vedere come sono a volte senza capelli a
volte troppo magre a volte su una
seggiola a rotelle a volte amputati
imputabili
ecco quando questo non è facile da
rappresentare così deve venire l'ironia
il gioco la leggerezza giusto guardate
quanti siano nati cioè da imprenditrice
illuminata voglio dire se ti sei
adeguata ecco questa creatività secondo
me dal dada dalla forza di essere quello
che che che in quel momento possiamo e
dobbiamo essere questo l'idea di darvi
un messaggio oggi non so quanto i minuti
mancano mattine manca abbiamo fatto e
finito abbiamo definito allora ragazzi e
questo il messaggio è che questa non
dovete per forza affacciarvi nome lei o
come me o non dovete giudicare però come
ha detto questo ragazzo straordinario
sulla sessualità non giudichiamo però
troviamo una soluzione per rimanere
autentici a noi stessi io mi occupo di
persona che muore e le persone quando
muoiono vogliono trovare una persona
innamorata di fronte a loro che abbia
una luce che abbia uno splendore tale da
dire io sono felice nonostante quindi il
messaggio e portiamo a casa li
l'autenticità di ciò che ci piace fare
essere e siate innamorati e per sé
quando siamo innamorati ci si fida a
cavallini io mi fido di se mi sono
fidata di ogni istante che ti è mai
proposto per questo io sono qui perché
ti voglio bene voglio volerti bene
fidarmi ancora ora si va via ragazzi vi
si lascia andare
è camadini bellissimo